hi this is a seminar dedicated to
enhanced rapid
ngs tools for viral research i am chris
kenros i work in global market
development
for the ngs on aluminum platform program
at thermo fisher scientific and thank
you i appreciate you joining us today
so we're going to spend our focus today
talking about viral research and
some tools that are now available to
make our research more accurate and a
little bit
faster everything we're going to talk
about today falls squarely within the
mission
of summer fisher scientific our mission
is to help
our customers to help you make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
and in the middle of a pandemic and in
security
in terms of safety there's no better
time to focus on this mission so
everything we're going to talk about
today fell squarely within
why we exist as a company and where
we're focused to help you in your work
so why mgs well there's a lot of ways to
tackle viral research and they're very
complementary and so ngs certainly isn't
the only technology that would be used
for viral research but one of the
benefits of ngs is that it is very very
fast and doesn't require prior
hypothesis or prior knowledge
if we take an example from the cyrus
cov2 pandemic that we're all living
through right now
and we look at lagos on february 27th
the first case was confirmed
by the first it had been sent for
sequencing and by the fourth
it had been published so the genome was
published
very rapidly within days of the first
induction
this is the benefit of mgs they were
able to move very fast and so
everything we're going to talk about
today needs to be dayton timestamp
this presentation is being given in june
of 2020.
the situation could possibly look very
different by november of 2020 or even
july of 2020
and so we will be very careful
throughout this conversation
to tell you exactly when the data was
collected to help you understand that
it's a snapshot in time
what doesn't change is that the approach
for viral research
is pretty consistent three phases phase
one happens very fast
it's the identification phase and this
is when we try to figure out
what is it that's making us sick does it
have a name already
if it has a name has it mutated does it
not have a name do we need to give it a
name
and assemble a novel genome this
typically happens
very quickly and this phase was really
completed by about the end of
december early january depending on
which
study you follow we then move
collectively
as a scientific community into a
positive feedback loop
of researching potential vaccines and
therapeutics
for this disease as well as monitoring
it
just to keep track of the new strains
that are emerging and make sure
that the work being done on vaccine and
therapeutic development
is not going to be negatively impacted
or changed because
of new strains of the virus that are
emerging so what are we going to talk
about today
well today we're actually going to talk
about a new portfolio from thermo fisher
scientific
called calibri and it's worth thinking
for a moment about
why now why didn't we do this 10 years
ago
so thermo fisher scientific has been in
conversation
with ngs labs around the world and
taking a close look at the technology
that was offered years ago and more
recently
we wanted to wait until we could offer
something better
and fix some of the problems that are
still there with older technology one of
the challenges with the older library
prep kids
is that after a day or two at the bench
working with clear liquids and clear
tubes
you run a bioanalyzer trace where you
sequence it and you find out
did you actually generate a library this
is a terrible way to approach
precious samples you really don't
want to wait that long to find out
if you're going to get usable
information out of it or not
there's got to be a better way and so
one of the first things we did was we
took a hard look at that question
is how can we improve the success rate
of samples and make sure
that you get feedback at every step that
things are going as intended
and so how we've done this is that we've
introduced
unique tracking dyes into each reagent
in the calibri portfolio you can see a
visualization here
where you can see two reagents being
added together and then thoroughly mixed
so calibri is a made-up word
it translates loosely into two latin
words meaning information
and full of color specifically says
these are libraries full of color
incrimination full of color so anytime
you see
a part of the calibri portfolio you'll
know that it has these tracking guides
so why is this important well these
tracking guides serve a couple of very
important
pieces of information the first is for
your robot
you need to know that each channel on
your multi-channel pipetter
is actually dispensing and re-pipetting
as
intended if you've got 96 samples or
more you don't want to wait until the
end
in qc to find out that one of your tips
was actually not seated firmly
and the library is gone you'll be able
to tell in the first step in that first
color change mixing step
that everything's fine the second area
where this is particularly helpful
is when training new employees you bring
a scientist into the lab to help during
surge capacity or as part of a training
exercise and now that scientists can see
at each step that things are happening
as intended
because that color change only happens
when the reagents are mixed
thoroughly the third area where this
helps is to avoid
over mixing your samples if you're
working in clear liquids with clear
tubes
you might go back and re-pipet and remix
it two
maybe three maybe even four times to
make sure that they're mixed
thoroughly doing that you are further
fragmenting your sample
and you might even be damaging some of
the enzymes inside depending on the
stuff that you're working on so it's
important to mix
thoroughly but you don't want to over
mix it and introduce damage to your
sample that wasn't there when you began
and so these reagents will change color
when mixing is complete
you're good you can keep going one of
the other areas that we've heard quite a
bit of feedback from
different labs is that there's an
incredible amount of time being spent on
sourcing
and this really falls into two
categories one is
just gathering the materials needed to
generate libraries
so you get indexed adapters from one
vendor you get your reagents from a
second
you probably get your purification your
cleanup beads from a third
you could even have a fourth vendor
involved for plastics and other
miscellaneous equipment
this is kind of a waste of the time it
would be much more efficient to just
have one catalog number and get
everything that you need
and know that those components were
intended to be used together
and that they were optimized to to work
together
rather than trying to hodgepodge
together different reagents and so what
we've done with the calibri portfolio
is that one catalog number will give you
everything that you need
you get indexed adapters with unique
dual indexes
for aluminum platforms you get a pcr
master mix
if you want something with pcr in it
there are pcr-free versions available
for whole genome sequencing if you
prefer that
you also get the clean up feeds you
don't need to go look for your amp here
just pull the bottle out of the kit and
you're good there's even spare
accessories such as seals
so today in the context of viral
research we are going to
focus on two primary categories of
library prep methods
we're going to talk about whole genome
sequencing and this is where we sequence
the host typically us with other animals
as well
also if you choose to reverse transcribe
the sars cov2 rna virus into cdna
you would use this approach after
reverse transcription
the second category is rna sequencing
we're going to talk about the
differences between
three different methods of whole
transcriptome sequencing
mrna sequencing and three prime mrna
sequencing
and talk about the trade-offs between
them and when they might be appropriate
for different areas of viral research
two other categories within the
portfolio we'll touch briefly on library
quantification at the end but there's
also a fourth category of library
amplification
and this is when you have very small
amounts of input you generate your
library
and then you need to amplify your
library in order to have enough to
perform
qc and sequencing or keeping some for
archival purposes
the unique feature about the
amplification option is that it doesn't
introduce any gc
bias it amplifies gc and at equally well
and so it's a way to
amplify other technology other kits and
generate more library
before we dive into how to do this let's
take a moment and think about what we're
actually doing why are we doing this
well
within the context of vaccine
development it's a very detailed fairly
long process and can last anywhere from
18 months
to decades depending on the particular
virus
under question today we're going to
focus on the discovery phase
and specifically we're going to focus on
the viral biology part
of the discovery phase thermo fisher
scientific can help with each of the
stages in vaccine development
all the way through pre-clinical
development and clinical development and
so if you'd like to have a conversation
about antigen design and discovery or
clinical trials how to manufacture at
scale please give us a call and we will
help you with those as well
within vaccine development some areas of
the genome and some areas of the ngs
data are going to be looked at a little
bit more closely than others and that's
because they're just simply more
relevant for vaccine development
one area that the scientific community
has been spending quite a bit of time on
is the 12th base insertion of the ace
ii protein within the spike protein and
so the reason for this
is that that 12 base insertion appears
to be the difference between
a year ago when we were all flying
around and attending weddings and
and now were those activities require
careful thought or
frankly should be avoided at all
depending on where you live
and the reason is those 12 faces are the
difference between this particular virus
being able to enter
our lungs or not within the phases of
viral surveillance and epidemiology
we're asking two questions the first
question is
are new viral strains emerging this
virus mutating and the answer is yes of
course all viruses mutate but more
importantly how quickly
and in what way and what is the impact
of those mutations
and so you can see a visualization here
on the left from nextdrain.org who's
done a really good job
of collecting genomes from sarsko v2
from around the world
and visualizing the emergence of these
strains so then the second question
being asked in this particular step is
okay so there's a new strain
what genetic mutations have occurred
that account
for that strain and so this allows us to
get to very detailed single base pair
resolutions without any prior
assumptions or hypotheses to study these
new viruses
we're also as a scientific community
monitoring
where these strains are where they're
going and where they've come from
at this point in time in june of 2020
this is particularly important in the
united states where it's currently
believed that there's one strain of the
virus that infected the east coast of
the united states and a different strain
that infected the west coast
and may have quite a bit of
impact in terms of outcomes for those
two groups of people
in terms of how many people became sick
and how ill they became
this is truly team science so one
example of
a collaborative initiative that is going
on is the cova 19 host genetics
initiative
now the screenshot shown here of members
of this initiative was taken in april
what i would encourage you to do is use
this url at the bottom
which is covaid19hg.org
partners and you can see a full list
with map
of everybody involved what's important
here is that the scientific community
regardless of background previous focus
area
or politics has rapidly come together
to tackle this pandemic and to work
together
and i'm so proud of this community
because these are groups that previously
might have competed for funding with
each other all of that is gone
everybody is working together this is
truly a collaborative experience
so that's what we're doing and why we're
doing it let's talk about
how how are we gonna do this well today
let's start with whole genome sequencing
now whole genome sequencing in the
context of stars cov2
could be done in two possible scenarios
or two primary possible scenarios the
first
is to understand genetic differences
among us as people
that might account for susceptibility to
infection
by the virus itself as well as different
strains of the virus
the other is that some labs are reverse
transcribing
this rna virus into cdna where it's a
little bit
safer and more stable and then going
into whole genome sequencing
so what we're going to talk about here
is applicable to either of those two
scenarios
and what's different about the calibre
test is several things
the first is that there is a pcr option
available so particularly
if you're going to sequence human
samples where
dna is a slightly more abundant pcr-free
might be a good way to go it saves time
and also reduces any possible risk of
bias
that could be introduced by pcr but
there's also an amplification version
and so the amplification version is
really good if you have minimal amounts
of sample
and it includes that library
amplification module that we spoke about
earlier in this conversation
where it amplifies atm gc equally well
and so it reduces quite a bit of bias
that you would have seen with older
library prep
technology is that we wanted to find out
with this new library amplification
module
what is the impact between pcr and not
pcr
is there an impact and so what we did
was we looked at two extremes we looked
at one nanogram of dna that was
amplified
in 12 cycles of pcr and compared it to a
thousand nanograms of dna
that was not amplified this particular
data is from
corial and the sequencing details are
noted at the bottom
we looked particularly at the categories
of snips and indels and specifically
comparing recall and precision and so
what you can see here in the data
is that they're almost the same so
whether you start with
very little and you amplify it or you
have
a great deal of dna to start with and
you don't amplify it
the results are nearly identical the one
exception
that we've seen is on indel recall you
do see a slight drop
one nanogram with amplification but it's
negligible when it varies by sample
we're very conservative in the
data that we show and so this is the
most extreme
difference that we've seen so how do we
do this well a couple of ways
the first is that unlike older
transposomic based methods
that by their very design are unable to
capture the ends of the fragments and
therefore can't possibly assemble a
complete genome with even coverage we've
gone with a classical approach of
shearing and ligation
but what's different is the thermo
fisher scientific is an enzyme company
we have a vast
catalog of reagents that have never been
released commercially and so we went
into our bag of tricks we looked to see
which enzymes were most
potent most specific and most
appropriate for sequencing
and we chose those the reagents and the
enzymes that are in these calibrate kits
are not in other kits these are truly
unique to calibri
so what you get from that is a very fast
protocol about an hour and a half
and very sensitive you don't need very
much dna in order to make this
successful
how do we look at this with real samples
gorilla data is nice
but what about real life samples the
data shown in the next few slides was
generated by dr carlos salvova and dr
vladimir venice at embl
and maserati university the slides are
actually from them
and we'd like to thank them personally
for sharing this information
what they did was they used the calibri
kits to look at a specific
type of sample that is historically very
challenging
and that is cell-free dna liquid biopsy
and so what they did was they wanted to
compare
using samples from patients who had been
diagnosed with chronic
lymphatic leukemia we wanted to see the
rate of detection of copy number
variations
between genomic dna tumor dna
solid tumor dna and cell free dna
because if the technology of the colibri
technology
is able to detect the same level of cnv
with the same accuracy
from very small amounts of cell free dna
as you can from solid tumor or from
genomic dna
that could potentially open up a great
deal of additional types of samples
with high confidence in the results the
reason cell free dna is
so difficult is that it's badly damaged
the average fragment size for cell free
dna is about 170 nucleotides long
it's also very rare you don't get
very much dna and so you cannot possibly
risk
losing any of it because you're not
going to get it back you didn't have
much to start with
and it's not easily recoverable so what
did they find
well looking at normal dna that was
obtained from buccal slabs
compared to solid tumor dna from uh
chronic lymphocytic leukemia cells as
well
as from cell free dna from plasma one
nanogram of input of cell free dna
from plasma justice 6x coverage produce
the same cnb
detection and sensitivity as 10
nanograms
of dna from other types of samples this
is pretty impressive
they took it one step further they said
okay so we can actually use this for
real samples and this is important
what about for more complicated types of
studies so what they did was they used
the calibri kits
to look at the next stage of research
and that is
really to look at samples that not only
had chronic lymphocytic leukemia but
also had ph negative myoproliferative
neoplasia
and so why this matters is that this is
an area
where therapeutic development is going
on and so they wanted to find out
again could they detect the same level
of copy number variation with the same
sensitivity of detection
from people who had donated samples who
had received
treatment versus samples that had not
received
treatment that would be the ultimate
test and so you can see what they found
here what they did was they compared
samples that had not
received any treatment again samples
from people who had received
treatment but were in remission
following the treatments
so you've got quite a complex cohort
going on here but this is real life
research
this is what we actually work with and
so normal dna
is at the top for control you can see
there aren't any copy number variations
there
next they looked at the cll samples
you could detect a copy number variation
without any treatment
then they went into the mpm condition
again you could
detect it with and without treatment and
still free dna within without treatment
and the takeaway here is that from very
small amounts of sample
they could actually take it all the way
through a therapeutic
study and make accurate insights
into whether that treatment was helping
or not first cozy ii
is an rna virus and our gene expression
as host could be incredibly important
particularly in areas of
immunology and our immune response to
this virus
and so within rna sequencing there's
three different techniques that are
being used to study not only the virus
itself
but also host pathogen interaction so
how do we interact with the virus
what is the impact of infection on our
immune system how do we react and is
there something about
our transcriptomes that could indicate
susceptibility or
predict potential outcomes when infected
these sequencing methods are quite
different from each other and provide
different types of information so what
we're going to do in the next few
minutes
is walk through the different options
and the trade-offs between them so that
we can think about
how to make decisions on which one is
appropriate for your particular project
goal
at a high level if we think about the
three different methods
you receive the most information the
most
insights from whole transcriptome
sequencing you get coding
and non-coding rna you can look at gene
expression analysis you can look at gene
fusion this really is the most complete
understanding of the phenotype
in order to get that level of insight
and that level of detail
it requires more reads it's simply the
reality of it so on an illumina system
generally 60 million reads for a human
sample is
kind of a minimum in order to get the
full information we've seen labs go up
to 100 million or 200 million reads
it's a lot of data to analyze but you
get a lot of insight out of it
where calibri can help with this is to
make the process of library generation
much easier it's a very rapid protocol
so including ribosomal depletion for
human muscle rats
the total workflow time to generate a
library it's only six and a half hours
so it's very very fast
and you start with total rna in this
particular type of sequencing
now because this particular sequencing
method of whole transcriptome sequencing
does require so much data a lot of
people go
to mrna sequencing as a proxy
or an initial step and the reason is
that while you don't
get non-coding rna from mrna sequencing
you do get the information on coding rna
you can look at gene expression analysis
infusions
and you can do it with fewer weights
typically about 30 million reads
for a human sample the culibri kit here
is again very very fast it's about a
four and a half hour protocol and it
contains those step-by-step
feedback in the form of the tracking
dies and here you actually start with
enriched
mrna the third category is rather new
this came out in the past year this is
called three prime mrna sequencing
this sequencing method is very specific
to gene expression analysis so if you're
trying to do gene expression profiles of
a large cohort of people
and you want to see what is the
difference among them you don't want to
spend an awful lot of time
digging into complex informatics or or
large amounts of sequencing this is the
right approach so
reprimander sequencing is interesting
because it only requires
somewhere between two and five million
reads for example not very much
also very fast protocol to generate the
libraries
about four and a half hours but it's
also extremely sensitive
you can go all the way down to 100
picograms of total rna if you wish
all the way up to 500 nanograms we have
a separate seminar if you're interested
in more detail
on three prime mrna sequencing please
reach out to your sales rep and we're
happy to share that with you
so we started the stranded whole
transcriptome sequencing so let's start
there as well
and look at that in a little bit more
detail i mentioned that this is very
very fast well it's also very low
hands-on time
so to generate a whole transcription
library you would deplete your ribosomal
rna
generate your library about three and a
half hours of hands-on time
in about six and a half hours of total
time everything within the colibri rna
portfolio is highly stranded
very easy there's a version of the kit
available for mrna sequencing
that does not include ribosomal
depletion reagents
so if you're not working with human
mouth or rat or
you really only want poly a enriched
mrna
the protocol is even faster it's about
four and a half hours of total time
and you need somewhere between 1 and 25
nanograms of enriched
mrna to use the kit within total rna
sequencing
this kit is designed in a different
manner from
older library prep technology and what
we've done
is create a kit where after you fragment
your rna
you add your helper adapters for
luminous systems what this means is that
you're adding adapters directly
to the rna not the cdna
why does this matter well when you add
your adapters directly to rna
and then you complete them into
full-length adapters later on during pcr
you actually capture the entire
transcriptome you get your coding and
you're not encoding but you also collect
small rna
you get a much richer robust
representation of what's in your sample
compared to older technology
where the adapters are added to cdna
there's too many cleanup steps to
generate cdna prior to adapter addition
so we flipped it and said okay we want
to sequence rna
let's put the adapter onto the rna then
we'll generate our cdna
and put it onto the sequencer at the
other end of the spectrum
is the three prime mrna sequencing test
that we've looked at
but this one's a little bit different
compared to whole transcriptome
this gives you gene expression profiles
it does not give you
everything this is a very focused
library prep sequencing method and so
what that focus allows you to do is a
couple of things
first of all it allows you to do very
short run lengths so a 1 by 50 base pair
or 1 by 75 base pair
is entirely sufficient to generate three
prime
mrna sequencing data that is accurate
and robust and the reason for that
is the way that the library technology
works
is that through a clever use of blocking
mechanisms
and very specific enzyme choices it does
two things
one it only captures the three prime end
next to the polyetail
but it also degrades the rna template in
the process of generating the library
what this gives you is the ability to
eliminate
length normalization it also tells you
that you do not have duplicates that
were
created by the library prep technology
by having the
rna template dissolve during library
preparation
this prevents library prep or technology
induced
duplicates you know that any duplicates
you're looking at in your data are true
biological
duplicates and not artifacts introduced
by the library prep technology
and this can really be helpful when
comparing gene expression profiles
across multiple samples
the other nice thing about three prime
mrna sequencing
is that because it only requires
somewhere between two and five million
reads
it expands the type of system that you
can use out of the aluminum portfolio
so if you require 60 million reads or
more in order
to do whole transcription sequencing
pretty much in the next secret nova
seeker hi-c category
but if you only need two to five million
reads you can now go down to a mini-seek
if you prefer
this gives you flexibility in timing and
cost
if you want to be able to run samples as
fast as they come in
run them on a miniseq if you want to
reduce the cost of sequencing chemistry
and you have a lot of samples to run
batch them together and put them onto a
novaseq you can actually
reduce your sequencing cost per library
down as far as five dollars per sample
by batching these libraries together
onto a novaseq
this is going to become particularly
important it's more and more and more
samples start to come in to the labs and
frankly start to flood into the blood
from people who are infected or not
infested with soros kobe 2 as we look at
these gene expression profiles
across individuals so we'd like to point
out some data that was generated from
dr nicholas maynard at tulane university
and the following slides all come from
dr maynard we thank him
for sharing them with us he used the
three prime mrna
sequencing calibri kit to look at zika
and zika is a very good system that was
available prior to sample availability
for stars kobe 2.
and previously sequencing was just
simply not affordable it wasn't within
the budget
for this particular group and so they
had been using a different technology
that you can see on the right
here so the first question is really how
much information
is obtained through three prime mrna
sequencing compared to the technology
that he was previously using
and so he compared samples from pregnant
females
that were infected with zika against
males
who were infected with zika to determine
the richness of data
now this this wasn't a gene expression
profile study where he truly wanted to
see what was the difference between a
pregnant female and a male
just not really the best comparison as
he very openly says what he wanted to
see was about
how much data how much information what
sort of insights would he see
and so he could quickly see there's a
big difference so at a lower cost for
example the three prime
mrna sequencing technology provided far
richer data sets
than he previously had been able to
receive using older technology
and so he took this a step further and
he took that three prime mrna sequencing
technology and
he's wanted to see what type of insights
could be gained from it
and so he was able to tell just from two
to five million reads
he was able to visualize depressed
leukocyte mobilization
he could look at a very specific and
extensive rich
list of enriched gene sets to look at
enhanced metabolic reprogramming
the amount of information provided from
three prime mrna sequencing is so robust
from a gene expression profile
perspective
this is more than just a technology to
be used for grant applications
this is actually providing at a very low
cost rich
data sets for biological insights
so we've talked about three different
rna sequencing library prep
methods we've talked about whole
transcriptome sequencing we've talked
about mrna sequencing
and we've talked about three prime mrna
sequencing
and how to choose between them depending
on if we want more data
at a higher cost or if we want gene
expression profiling
at a lower cost or somewhere in the
middle but how do you analyze this
well if you have an information that is
available and pipelines in place
fabulous go with those if your
information is currently a bit
backlogged or quite frankly the demand
is simply higher than
you can keep up with using an
information we do have an agreement with
genie alice shown here to analyze data
what genealogy has done is to integrate
all three
of the colibri rnac library prep kits
into their platform their analysis
platform so you can upload your fast
queues
and point and click and generate your
annotation
you can look at gene expression
differences you can do your
visualizations
they actually produce images and reports
that are suitable for publication if
that's
your purpose for the study quite a quite
a nice system actually
what we do is we encourage you using the
email at the bottom
to reach out to them if you'd like to
have a demo or to find out about costing
on this
this software is designed for biologists
this is not necessarily designed for
information
although information might find it
completely helpful as well
if you are working on sarsko b2 we
encourage you to reach out to them using
that
email because they will offer the
software to you
at no cost there's a lot of different
ways
to look at this data we're going to just
look at two here
thermo fisher scientific doesn't
formally endorse or recommend any
particular visualization
tool or analysis package beyond the
genialis software but you can see
examples here
the scientific community has come
together to develop quite a few packages
specifically to help with this pandemic
so we've looked at nextdrain.org
in detail earlier in this conversation
another option
comes from onramp there's a url there
that you can see and
they've done quite a bit of work making
making their software compatible with
many different databases but also to
compare for example
if you want to look across multiple
coronavirus strains
for similarities or differences it's
very easy to do with their system
i mentioned at the beginning of this
discussion category three within the
portfolio
which was library quantification so the
library quantification
within the colibri portfolio is qpcr
it has those tracking guides everything
is master mix the calibri library
quantification kit
was designed to be a little bit easier
and a little bit faster
to perform qpcr quantification of mgs
libraries for illumina systems
so it doesn't really matter which
particular library prep kit you choose
you can quantify it using
the delivery kit so we show here some
data comparing against another option
out there
we show here data comparing against
another option in the market
four genomes of different gc content and
different sizes
you can see different library sizes
indicated in the parentheses
so for example homo sapien libraries
were a little bit shorter
in this particular test compared to
pseudomonas which was a little bit
longer so it's essentially the same
so what this means is that you can have
the master mixes
of the qpcr kit and that visual feedback
without throwing out years of data
essentially the same it's qpcr so today
we've talked about
whole genome sequencing for human and
reverse transcribed stars cov2
we've looked at three different
sequencing methods within rna sequencing
again to sequence the virus
to sequence us to look at interactions
between the two
and we've touched briefly on library
quantification samples are available for
everything in the portfolio
and they're very easy to request simply
go to thermofisher.com
calibri samples let us know which one
you'd like to try and where
we should send it we'll send you out a
free sample these samples are a
full-size kit
so the library prep reaction samples are
24 reactions
but in addition to sending a sample we
also offer a lot of other help
at no cost if you'd like us to look at
bioanalyzer traces or other qc data
prior to going into sequencing sure we
can do that for you
if you need recommendations on how to
modify a protocol for your particular
sample
or experimental goals we're happy to do
that for you as well
very easy to work with us with that i'd
like to say thank you
thank you for joining us in this
discussion but also thank you for the
work that you're doing
the work that you're doing or planning
to do
could be the difference between all of
us being able to figure out
what normal looks like and having sars
kobe 2 become a little bit less of a
fear and a little bit less of a threat
we have a lot of work to get to a new
normal but the work that you're doing is
very important
we thank you have a good day take care